Here it is,...
...the site of the most highly anticipated wedding in Britain in years:...
...St. George's Chapel, where Prince Harry and Meghan Markle will tie the knot...
...here on the grounds of Windsor Castle.
With its vaulted ceilings and striking stained glass,...
...it's considered a masterpiece of Gothic architecture.
Plans to build St. George's Chapel got underway in 1475.
It took more than 50 years to complete.
By the time it was done, the man in charge was the infamous King Henry VIII.
Centuries later, his body remains interred here,...
...next to that of his third wife, Jane Seymour.
Here is the famous aisle where Harry and Meghan will walk in...
...and later walk out as newlyweds.
It's not as wide and grandiose as Westminster Abbey,...
...where William married Kate or St. Paul's Cathedral,...
...where Charles married Diana, but many royals have tied the knot right here.
In fact, Harry himself was carried in...
...at just three months old to be baptized right here.